I love close-ups in IMAX because
the expressions of the actors
and the nuance just comes out better in IMAX.
Joaquin and I spend a ton of time together
just talking about Arthur and Joker
and where the laugh comes from
and what Arthur looks like
and how Arthur walks and talks
and obviously things you talk about with actors
in general.
But with Joaquin,
it always seems to go a little bit deeper.
I've never really met an actor like Joaquin.
He made the process uniquely thrilling.
[Laughter]
[Music]
You're not immune sitting at the desk
you're in it.
and you feel the character
you feel the emotion
and you feel what he's doing.
I used to think that
my life was a tragedy
but now I realize
it's a comedy.
As the dialogue mixer,
there's a lot that I will do
from a mixing standpoint
to push some of the intimacy moments
with him and things where I can actually
make it feel like you are closer to him
maybe closer to him than you want to be
at times.
I love the way the Gotham looks
in this movie.
The sirens sound different
they don't sound like New York sirens
and that was another tall order
that Todd wanted.
We weren't supposed to make
Hill Street Blues quote unquote
we were supposed to make Gotham.
The character of Arthur is a slow burn
turning into Joker
so part of the magic of Joaquin
is that ability to kind of tweak the performance
so that transformation happens so slowly.
We had to sonically take the ride with Arthur
from where you saw him
to where he ends up.
Playing with that was a lot of fun
but it's a very delicate tricky thing.
As he transforms
the lighting gets a bit darker
camera gets a bit lower
he becomes a bit more grand.
I've been fortunate enough to six movies with Todd.
On this movie
more than any we've ever done before
we would just constantly remind ourselves
there's no compromise here.
This has to be the best thing we've ever done.
You know, pressure makes diamonds.
It is unlike any other DC movie
you have ever seen.
I think that a lot of people
are gonna be surprised by Joker.
You're gonna walk away questioning some things.
It's a good ride
that's for sure.
Seeing it in IMAX is just gonna heighten
that experience.
It's just the experience you can't get
anywhere else.